hello and welcome to the shaky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about car t-cells a therapy that is
currently being developed for cancer
treatments and how recent study have
instead used this technique to try and
target senescence cells and sets so
we'll begin with a discussion of what
actually are car t-cells and then we'll
go into the paper and see some of the
results they got by instead targeting
senescence cells and so obviously we'll
talk about how they actually managed to
use this approach to target senescence
cells so the paper I'll be focusing on
is semi lytic car T cells were first
senescence associated pathologies that
came out in nature just the well just
the other week
and as from Scott Lowe's lab so we'll
begin by talking about car T cells so my
own understanding of car T cells came
back in 2017 which feels quite a while
ago now but still feels pretty recent to
me and I felt like I was pretty late to
the table in terms of understanding this
technology and in my entertaining blog I
rates back in 2017 describes learning
about car cells a WoW moment in my life
so what actually is this technology so
this technology depends on T cells and T
cells are a key component of our immune
system this is because T cells provide
cell mediated immunity against various
pathogens including viruses and the way
that they do this is by having receptors
on the surface of the cells which
recognize antigens found all these
different pathogens and so what is an
antigen well it's basically a fancy word
for molecules that are recognized by the
immune system so when this t-cell
mediated immunity the T cells recognized
the antigens and caused destruction of
the cell however a key call mark of
cancer cells is a fasion of the T cell
immune response car T cell therapy
provides a way this issue can be
overcome it invokes modifying the T
cells by genetically engineering them to
display cell surface
that recognize antigens on cancer cells
the [ __ ] cells are then recognized and
destroyed and so this is why the name
car comes from because it stands for
chimeric antigen receptor so an
important consideration for this
approach is to identify antigens that
are unique to the cancer cells and so
this prevents normal healthy cells from
being destroyed so does this therapy
actually work well I haven't entirely
kept up to date with this field because
it isn't really my area of expertise but
what I do know is that this car t-cell
therapy is pretty well regarded for
being effective for b-cell acute
lymphoblastic leukemia whereby the T
cells were engineered to recognize a
protein that's expressed on these
cancerous B cells as clinical trials
were successful this technique has been
given FDA approval however some patients
that develop a cytokine release syndrome
which is is the fair inflammatory
response that can result in high fevers
or they they essentially were managed
another concern is how pricey these
treatments actually are so to summarize
car T cells in one sentence chimeric
antigen receptors are synthetic
reporters that redirect t-cell
specificity all right
so given that you now understand what
car t-cells
are and how they can be used to target
cancer cells can they now be used to
target senescent cells so firstly well
actually a senescent cells well there
are some pretty good videos that I could
redirect you to that explains that
sounds very well but I will just give a
brief overview here so senescence cells
are cells that have undergone cellular
senescence that is characterized by G
major hallmarks one of which is a stable
cell cycle arrest and the other is a
secretory phenotype that modulates the
surrounding environment of the cell some
essent cells have been shown to have
beneficial features such as acting as a
tumor suppressive mechanism to prevent
tumor developments
of mutated and damaged cells and also in
processors such as wound healing however
senescence cells have also been shown to
accumulate with age and due to their
secretary phenotype they can promote a
pro-inflammatory phenotype that can
result in chronic inflammation chronic
inflammation is then thought to drive a
variety of different age associated
diseases this includes liver and lung
fibrosis at there is chlorosis diabetes
and osteoarthritis the removal of
senescence cells in mouse models has
been shown to improve longevity and to
alleviate the symptoms of these
different diseases and so this has given
rise to great interest in finding ways
of removing senescence cells and so in a
pretty recent video I talked about two
different approaches one of which uses
Sano lytx which are drugs that can
induce a cell that is senescence to
undergo cell death and I also speak
about a genetic approach so is there any
way that
Carty cell technology can be used to
remove senescence cells
well this recent nature paper seems to
suggest that the answer is yes so how
did they do it well firstly they needed
to identify the antigen so a protein
target that's present on senescence
cells that isn't found on normal healthy
cells that they could then use to
develop the chimeric antigen receptor
that they have and the engineered T
cells so the way that they did this was
by looking at genes expressed in
senescence cells and healthy cells and
seeing what genes were really high into
nessam cells but really low in normal
cells and beyond this they also wanted
to look at genes that encode proteins
that are receptor proteins therefore
they're going to be recognizable by the
T cells because they're expressed on the
surface of the cell the protein target
that they decided on was Gary kinase
type plasminogen activator of receptor u
pas and this protein
is a receptor for the euro kinase type
plasminogen activator which promotes the
degradation of the extracellular matrix
and concurrently functions as a
signaling receptor that promotes
motility of the cell interestingly a
portion of ye pas is cleaved during
senescence to form soluble ye PHA or
super in this case and what is so super
about super is that it is found in the
plasma and so it can be used as a
biomarker to assess the Sony lytic
activity of the Senna lytic car t-cells
so with their target chosen they
constructed you pass specific car
t-cells to test the efficacy of these
cells the team used mouse models of
either lung cancer or liver fibrosis so
starting with the lung cancer mice a
potential strategy to treat the mice is
to use drugs that induced senescence in
the cells and to combine these trunks
with Senna lytic agents to then remove
the cells and indeed there has been
shown previously that this improved
outcome in mouse models so what they did
in this case was give the mice with the
lung cancer these drugs and also the car
T cells that are targeting you part
expressing cells interestingly they saw
that treatment with the car T cells
improved the survival without eliciting
signs of toxicity which was quite
promising results but besides cancer
senescent cells the 4c been shown to
contribute to fibrosis so this time they
looked at the impact of using car T
cells against senescence cells in mouse
models of liver fibrosis so if you look
at the results in this figure here we
can see that the mice that were treated
with the car T cells targeting dupa
showed a reduction in the level of
fibrosis and also a reduction in the
level of the senescence cells we showed
well it seems to show you that the use
of these car T cells was effective at
removing the senescence cells in the
liver it is interesting to point out
though that they tried this with two
different doses or
the car T cells the my circuit the lower
effects of those remains highly active
during the treatment phase whether the
mice that were given the higher dose a
super therapeutic dose actually
presented with hyperthermia
and weight loss along with an increase
in cytokines such as interleukin 6
suggestive of this car t-cell associated
cytokine release syndrome but since a
lower dose was still effective this may
not be a major issue so just the
summarize we'll consider some of the
kids and potential bad consequences of
using car t-cells for targeting
senescent cells so firstly I'm just
gonna say we'll say that it's a very
creative idea and if any of you watched
my last video I definitely put this as
combinatorial creativity because it uses
different aspects of science that we've
already known about such as the car
t-cells but applied it to any concept
which is senescent cells which i think
was a really cool and interesting idea
sometimes of the the good prospects
obviously these they seem to show him
the study that these car t-cells are
effective and also because senescent
cells aren't concurrently dividing like
a tumor cell it might mean that the
number of times that someone would be
treated with the car t-cells could be
very low because there's like a one time
thing
so that could potentially be good also
as I mentioned earlier there is the
potential use of having the biomarker of
the CEPA however I think in this case
there's probably other markers that
should be identified that could be more
effective or coach a greater specificity
for certain types of senescence cells
minimizing the risk of any of these car
T cells actually targeting healthy
normal cells so definitely the safety
profile and also whether or not this
would ever be effective in humans
definitely needs to be analyzed father
but I think the other thing that should
be said is that these treatments aren't
particularly cheap that is you're quite
expensive choose the the nature of
having to actually reprogram these T
cells and so one could argue that if we
find Senna lytic drugs that are more
effective this could definitely just be
an easier option but I think still this
is definitely an interesting
tool that they've developed and the
results do seem promising so yeah that's
all I really have to say so I hope you
have learned something in this video and
as always thanks for listening